in this video we're going to start
having some experience solving
radical equations or equations that
involve square roots or maybe even
higher power roots but we're going to
also try to understand
an interesting phenomena that occurs
when we do these equations let me show
you what i'm talking about let's have
the equation the square root of x
is equal to 2 times x
minus 6. now one of the things you're
going to see whenever we do these
radical equations is we want to isolate
at least one of the radicals there's
only one of them in this equation and
when you isolate one of the radicals on
one side of the equation this one starts
off like that i have the square root of
x isolated on the left-hand side then we
square both sides of the equation so let
us square
both sides of the equation so i'll just
rewrite it again we'll do this one
slowly i'm going to square that and
that's going to be equal to
2x minus 6
squared and squaring seems like a valid
operation if that is equal to that then
that squared should also be equal to
that squared so we just keep on going
so when you take the square root of x
and you square it that'll just be x
and we get x is b is equal to
this squared is going to be 2x squared
which is 4
x squared it's 2x squared the whole
thing 4x squared and then you multiply
these two which is
negative 12x and it's going to be twice
that so minus 24x
and then negative 6 squared is plus 36.
if you found
going from this to this difficult you
might want to review multiplying
polynomial expressions or multiplying
binomials or actually the special case
where we square binomials but the
general view it's this squared which is
that
and then you have minus 2 times the
product of these two the product of
those two is minus 12x or negative 12x 2
times that is negative 24x and then that
squared so this is what our equation has
i guess we could say simplify to and
let's let's see what happens if we
subtract x from both sides of this
equation so if you subtract x from both
sides of this equation the left-hand
side becomes 0 and the right-hand side
becomes 4
x squared
minus 25 x
plus 36. so this radical equation has
simplified to just a standard quadratic
equation
and just for simplicity not having to
worry how to factor it and group it in
all of that let's just use the quadratic
formula
so the quadratic formula tells us that
our solutions to this x can be negative
b
negative 25 the negative of negative 25
is positive 25
plus or minus the square root
of 25 squared 25 squared is
625
minus 4
times a which is 4
times c which is 36
all of that over
2 times 4 all of that over 8. so let's
get our calculator out to figure out
what this is
over here
let's get our calculator out
so let's say so we have 6 25
minus let's see this is going to be
16 times 36 16 times 36
is equal to 49 that's nice it's a nice
perfect square we know what the square
root of 49 is it's 7. so let me go back
to the problem so this in here
simplified to 49 so x is equal to 25
plus or minus the square root of 49
which is 7
all of that over 8. so our two solutions
here if we add 7 we get x is equal to 25
plus 7 is 32
32 over 8 which is equal to 4 and then
our other solution let me do that in a
different color
x is equal to 25 minus 7 which is 18
over 8. 8 goes into 18 two times
remainder 2 so this is equal to 2 and 2
8 or 2 and 1 4 or 2.25
just like that
now i'm going to show you an interesting
phenomena that occurs and maybe you
might want to pause it after i show you
this conundrum although i'm going to
tell you why this conundrum pops up
let's try out to see if our solutions
actually work so let's try x is equal to
4. so this if x is equal to 4 works we
get the principal root of 4 should be
equal to 2 times 4
minus 6. the principal root of 4 is
positive 2. positive 2 should be equal
to 2 times 4 which is 8 minus 6 which it
is this is true
so 4
works
now let's try to do the same with 2.25
according to this we should be able to
take the square root the principal root
of 2.2 let me be
let me make my radical a little bit
bigger the principal root of 2.25 should
be equal to 2 times 2.25
minus
6.
now you may or may not be able to do
this in your head you might know that
the square root of 225
is 15 and then from that you should you
might be able to figure out that the
square root of 2.25 is 1.5 but let's
let me just use the calculator to verify
that for you
so 2.25 take the square root it's 1.5
the principal root is 1.5
another squared is negative 1.5 so it's
1.5
and then according this this should be
equal to 2 times 2.25 is 4.5
minus 6.
now does this is this true this is
telling us that 1.5 is equal to negative
1.5 this is not true 2.5 did not work
for this radical equation we call this
an extraneous solution
so 2.25
is
extraneous extraneous solution
now here's the conundrum why did we get
2.25 as an answer it looks like we did
very valid things the whole way down and
we got a quadratic and we got 2.25 and
there's a hint here right when we
substitute 2.25 we get 1.5 is equal to
negative 1.5 so there's something here
that something we did gave us this
solution that doesn't quite apply over
here
and i'll give you another hint let's try
it at this step if you look at this step
you're going to see that both solutions
actually work
so you could try it out if you like
actually try it out on your own time put
put in 2.25 for x here you're going to
see that it works put in 4 for x here
and you see that they both work here so
they're both valid solutions to that
they're both valid solutions to that so
something happened when we squared
that made the equation a little bit
different there's something slightly
different about this equation than that
equation and the answer is is there's
two ways you could think about it
to go back
from this equation to that equation
we take the square root but to be more
particular about it we are taking the
principal root of both sides now you
could take the negative square root as
well
notice this is only taking the principle
square root go going from this right
here let me let me be very clear this
statement
we already established that most both of
these solutions both the valid solution
and the extraneous solution to this
radical equation satisfy this right here
only the valid one satisfies the
original problem so let me write the
equation that both of them satisfy
because this is really an interesting
conundrum and it i think it gives you a
little bit of a nuance and kind of tells
you what's happening when we take
principal roots of things and why when
you square both sides you are to some
degree you can either think of it as
losing or gaining some information now
this can be written as
this could be written as x is equal to
2 x
minus 6 squared this is one valid
interpretation of this equation right
here but there's a completely other
legitimate interpretation of this
equation this could also be
we could this could also be x is equal
to
negative 1
times 2x minus 6
squared and why are these equal
interpretations because when you square
the negative 1 the negative 1 will
disappear right these are equivalent
statements and another way of writing
this one
another way of writing this right here
is that x is equal to you multiply
negative 1 times that you get negative
2x plus 6 or 6 minus 2x
squared
this and this are two ways of writing
our two ways of writing that
now when we took our square root or when
we i guess there's two ways you can
think about it
when we squared it we assuming we're
assuming that this was the only
interpretation but this was the other
one so we found two solutions to this
but only
only four
satisfies this interpretation right here
i hope you get what i'm saying because
we're kind of only taking you can kind
of imagine it the positive square root
we're not considering the negative
square root of this because when you
take the square root of both sides to
get here we're only taking the principal
root another way to view it let me
rewrite the original equation
let me rewrite the original equation
we had the square root of x is equal to
2 x
minus 6.
now we said 4 is a solution
2.25 isn't a solution 2.25 would have
been a solution if we said both of the
square roots of x
is equal to 2x minus 6. now you try it
out and 2.25
will have a valid solution here if you
take the negative square root of 2.25
that is equal to 2 times 2.25
so that is equal to 4.5 minus 6 which is
negative 1.5 that is true the positive
version is where you get x is equal to
4. so that's why we got two solutions
and if you square this maybe this is an
easier way to remember it if you square
this
if you square this
you actually get this equation that both
solutions are valid now that you might
have found that a little bit confusing
and all that i my intention is not to
confuse you the simple thing to think
about when you when you're solving
radical equations is look isolate
radicals square keep on solving you
might get more than one answer plug your
answers back in answers that don't work
they're extraneous solutions but most of
my explanation in this video is really
why does that extraneous solution pop up
and hopefully i gave you some intuition
that our our equation is the square root
of x the extraneous solution would be
valid if we took the plus or minus
square root of x not just the principal
root